Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Vous êtes environ 1 600 devant moi.
Savez-vous que, dans l’année qui vient,
400 d’entre vous seront touchés
dans leur santé mentale.
Et -
Eh oui !
Et moins de la moitié
ira chercher de l’aide.
Santé mentale, de quoi parlons-nous ?
Je vais vous prendre
quelques petits exemples.
Séverine.
Séverine,
une jeune femme qui dernièrement
a eu un accident de la circulation.
Rien de bien grave en apparence,
juste de la tôle froissée.
Pourtant,
aujourd’hui encore, Séverine est en
incapacité de monter dans une voiture.
Sa vie, son avenir en sont perturbés.
Comment aider Séverine ?
Que lui dire ?
Que faire ?
Pierre.
Pierre est agent
dans un service technique.
Vendredi dernier, c’était le pot
de départ d’un de ses collègues.
Toute l'équipe était réunie, sauf Pierre.
Ses collègues s’interrogent :
« Mais Pierre, habituellement,
aime bien ces moments festifs. »
Un autre constate :
« Depuis quelque temps, Pierre,
au moment des pauses-café,
est bien en retrait, bien silencieux. »
Un autre, qui est passé devant
chez lui dernièrement, a remarqué :
son jardin, sa passion
est devenue une friche.
Pierre ne va pas bien.
Mais que peut-on faire ?
Comment l’aider ?
Que lui dire ?
Jérémy.
Jérémy est cadre
dans un service administratif.
Il partage son bureau depuis plusieurs
années avec le même collègue.
Dernièrement, le chef de service
rentre dans le bureau :
« Comment ça, Jérémy n’est pas encore là ?
J’attends son dossier
depuis un certain temps.
Il est encore à la bourre. »
Le chef parti, le collègue
s’autorise à ouvrir le bureau
et là, point de dossier,
mais une bouteille de whisky.
Le collègue comprend mieux
les changements d’attitude
de Jérémy depuis quelque temps.
Mais que va-t-il faire de ce constat ?
Comment va-t-il pouvoir aller vers lui,
l’aider ?
Marie.
Marie est suivie
par un service d’insertion.
Sa conseillère constate qu’à chaque fois
qu’elle lui pose une question,
Marie tourne la tête sur le côté,
marque un temps de pause
avant de lui répondre.
Intriguée, elle demande :
« Marie, mais pourquoi ce geste ?
Pourquoi cette attitude ? »
Alors Marie de lui expliquer :
« Avant de vous répondre, je dois demander
à la petite Marie à côté de moi. »
Vous l’avez compris,
la situation de Séverine,
c’est celle de quelqu’un
qui est touché par un trouble anxieux,
comme 14% de la population.
Pierre, lui, traverse certainement
un épisode dépressif
comme 7% de la population.
Quant à Jérémy, pas besoin d’être expert
pour comprendre que ses troubles
sont liés à une addiction,
comme près de 5% de la population.
Marie,
c’est peut-être un peu plus rare
de croiser quelqu’un
qui traverse un trouble psychotique,
mais c’est toutefois quand même
près de 2% de la population.
Des Pierre, Marie, Jérémy, Séverine,
j’en ai croisé des milliers
dans ma carrière
au service de l’inclusion des personnes
présentant des troubles psychiques.
Mais vous, vous en croisez
aussi tous les jours.
Comme beaucoup,
vous êtes dans l’ambivalence
entre passer son chemin,
fermer les yeux ou tendre la main.
Ce constat, le fait que
les questions de santé mentale soient une
problématique majeure de santé publique,
ont amené les Australiens
à inventer un programme
qui s’appelle « Premier secours
en santé mentale ».
Il s’agit d’amener dans la population
des connaissances de base
sur ce que sont ces problématiques,
d’informer sur des gestes,
les premiers gestes basiques
qui peuvent aider quelqu’un
à se sortir de cette situation.
Ce, à l’équivalent
du premier secours physique.
Cette formation a été diffusée
dans 25 pays dans le monde,
et il y a trois ans, nous,
l’Association PSSM France,
Premier Secours en Santé Mentale France,
avons décidé de l’importer
en France et de l’adapter.
L’objectif : former 700 000
citoyens d’ici 2030.
Il ne s’agit pas de former
des experts, des soignants,
mais simplement des personnes
capables de faire le premier pas,
de tendre la main vers quelqu’un
qui est en difficulté.
Cette formation va apporter
des repères de base
pour comprendre ce que sont
les problèmes de santé mentale ;
va aider à ce qu’on puisse identifier
quelqu’un qui est en difficulté,
repérer ses problèmes ;
va aussi guider pour savoir
comment aller vers ces personnes,
comment les écouter,
comment apporter cette première aide.
Elle va aussi donner des indications
pour savoir comment intervenir
si la situation est
une situation de crise.
Elle va informer sur les ressources
qui peuvent être mobilisées.
Elle va aussi, et c’est important,
tordre le cou à un certain
nombre d’idées fausses
qui stigmatisent,
qui alimentent des peurs injustifiées
et qui font reculer l’accès aux soins.
Car il faut être convaincu
que cet accès rapide aux soins
est essentiel pour
les personnes en difficulté.
Il faut savoir que la majorité
des personnes qui vont se faire aider
vont se rétablir et retrouver
une existence satisfaisante.
Il faut aussi faire savoir
que l’aide première,
c’est celle des proches, des amis,
de ceux qui sont dans l’entourage.
Cette formation, elle est
accessible à tous, sans prérequis.
Elle dure 14 h.
Elle est organisée en petits groupes
et elle est disponible
sur l’ensemble du territoire.
Alors, vous qui connaîtrez un ami,
un voisin, un collègue,
un proche en difficulté
dans sa santé mentale,
soyez prêt à lui tendre la main.
Devenez secouriste en santé mentale.
(Applaudissements)